[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka guten Abend aus
den großen Ferien zurückkommen und als
erstes gleich mal Krach mit den
Klassenkameraden und schlechte Noten um
die Ohren gehauen bekommen auch nicht
die Art von Start die sich die Ampel
Koalitionäre zum Neustart nach der
Sommerpause wünschten Kraft gibt es
wegen der Kindergrundsicherung und die
schlechten Noten die hatte heute der
Klimarat verteilt jene Expertengruppe
die die Klimaschutzmaßnahmen der
Bundesregierung regelmäßig bewährt das
Klimaschutzprogramm sei nicht
ausreichend um die selbst gesetzten
Ziele zu erreichen außerdem mangelhaft
in der Bereitstellung nachvollziehbarer
Daten das jetzt natürlich vor allem die
Grünen unter Druck die ihren Wählern
anderes versprochen hatten Patricia
Wiedemeier Bericht
Zufall oder auch nicht nicht quatschen
machen steht da groß geschrieben in der
Handwerkskammer in Dresden es könnte
auch das Motto der diesjährigen
Sommerreise der Grünen Parteichefin sein
genau das bekommt Ricarda lang zu hören
egal wo sie ist heute morgen in Dresden
gestern in der Lausitz im
braunkohleabbaugebiet bei der leaag
überall wird die Energiewende
vorbereitet überall fehlen dafür jedoch
die politische Unterstützung aus Berlin
was Genehmigung betrifft Ausschreibung
für Gaskraftwerke wir haben sehr Herrn
Harbeck der war ja zweimal jetzt hier
eine Region wir waren auch schon dort
mehrmals gesagt wir haben die Fachkräfte
heute und morgen jetzt brauchen wir die
politischen Beschlüsse bei der LEA z.B
in Spremberg nahe Cottbus werden die
Azubis nicht mehr für den Bergbau
sondern als Industriemechaniker als
Mechatroniker ausgebildet denn mit der
Braunkohle soll ja 2038 Schluss sein die
Forderung der Grünen schon 20 30
auszusteigen hält hier keiner für
realistisch der alternativen so schnell
nicht vorhanden sein
das geht nicht also technisch wie auch
von der Logistik her die ganzen Sachen
müssen erstmal geplant werden gut ist
vielleicht die ganzen Sachen müssen
gebaut werden die Leute fürs Bauen
müssen ja erstmal rein geschafft werden
das sind so viele logistische Sachen die
einfach nicht erreicht werden können
wenn die Politik nicht auf die Leute vor
Ort höre auf die die eigentlich wissen
wie es geht führe doch genau das zur
Politikverdrossenheit meinen Sie hier
und fordern dass man sich mit Experten
aus industriewissenschaft und
Bildungsinstituten Fraunhofer-Institut
und so weiter zusammensetzen Lösungen
findet und vielleicht uns hier an der
Basis sage ich mal irgendwann fragt wie
läuft's denn was braucht er denn wie
lange braucht er denn wirklich und das
realistisch zu beurteilen und nicht mit
politischen Agenten zu vermischen
ricarda-lang selber nimmt nach dem
Besuch hier die Zahl 20 30 als
Ausstiegsdatum erstaunlicherweise nicht
mehr in den Mund
für mich steht heute hier nicht das
Ausstiegsdatum in Zentrum wenn ich als
vorher schon gesagt die Voraussetzung
dafür auszusteigen wird es immer sein
dass neue aufzubauen das neue Aufbauen
der Vorstand der lea-demonstriert den
Besuch aus Berlin dass man in der Praxis
viel weiter sein könnte wenn denn die
Politik die Rahmenbedingungen dafür
endlich schaffen würde die Lausitz soll
zu einem neuen green Valley werden mit
lauter Windkraftanlagen solarfeldern
Gaskraftwerken auch für Wasserstoff und
Batterie Fabriken statt Kohlekraftwerken
die Rahmenbedingungen für Investition
müssen geklärt werden speziell für die
für die H2O Kraftwerke die
Genehmigungsprozesse müssen noch mal
stark verschlankt werden für PV Wind und
alle anderen Themen das heißt der ganze
Apparat der im Hintergrund Luft läuft
muss verschlankt und reduziert werden in
Deutschland Geschwindigkeit die er so
gelobt wird in letzter Zeit die haben
noch lange nicht erreicht
das bestätigte heute in Berlin auch der
unabhängige Expertenrat für Klimafragen
die Ziele für 20 30 sein nicht
erreichbar die bisherigen Maßnahmen viel
zu wage es gebe kein schlüssiges Konzept
ein vernichtendes Urteil
was findet kaum die Regierung hat uns
ein Puzzle mit 1000 Puzzleteilen gegeben
sind auch 1000 Teile aber wir haben da
festgestellt die bestehen aus drei
verschiedenen puzzeln und jetzt haben
wir hier ein Stück und da ein Stück und
Darmstück den Kanzler ficht das alles
nicht an bezeichnenderweise besichtigte
er heute in Nordrhein-Westfalen ein
Windpark er verweist auf alle Maßnahmen
die die Regierung schon ergriffen habe
von Kritik an der Klimapolitik will er
nichts hören die große ökologische
industrielle Modernisierung unseres
Deutschland schreitet mit großem Tempo
voran
zur Sommerreise der grün
en sie hin kam wurde ihr vermittelt neue
Technologien müssen wir ja gefördert
werden wenn die Energiewende wirklich
gelingen soll jetzt geht's natürlich
darum dass wir die notwendigen
politischen Schritte auf den Weg bringen
das zu unterstützen da reden wir ganz
klar über Bürokratie Abbau
Überregulierung abbauen mehr
Digitalisierung weniger Formulare Erfolg
ist mein Ziel Wissen mein Weg steht
diesmal an der Wand vielleicht sollten
alle Koalitionspartner mal hierher
kommen
Klimaforscher verweisen ja darauf dass
im Zuge des Klimawandels mit häufigerem
und länger andauernden Extremwetter zu
rechnen ist dazu gehören auch solche
Hitzewellen wie sie wie wir sie im
Moment wieder in Europa erleben dass
solche extremen Temperaturen vor allem
für alte und kranke Menschen gefährlich
sind ist bekannt sie haben aber auch
besondere Auswirkungen auf Kinder
insbesondere Kleinkinder damit befasst
sich eine neue Studie des
Kinderhilfswerks UNICEF
dazu Bericht von Christine Elsner und
Barbara Völkel
an heißen Tagen hat die Kinderärztin dr
Annette kornbrust in ihrer Kölner Praxis
besonders viel zu tun die hohen
Temperaturen schwächen das Immunsystem
der kleinen die Kinder kommen mehr zum
Beispiel das Kind mit Neurodermitis das
dann heftige Ekzemschübe hat wenn zu
heiß ist oder sehr starke Bakterien
Hautinfektionen die haben wir vorher nie
so in der Häufung gesehen erstmal
Anfälle bei Kindern die eigentlich
gesund sind weil einfach das Boden nahe
Ozon bei Hitze steigt oder was ganz
wichtig ist was viele Leute noch gar
nicht wissen dass es in der
Schwangerschaft in hitzephasen in der
Frühschwangerschaft häufiger zu viel
Bildung kommt denn Hitze beeinträchtigt
die Versorgung des Ungeborenen mit
Sauerstoff auch bei der herzkranken Levi
ist das Risiko groß
intensive Sonneneinstrahlung extreme
Trockenheit und hohe ozonbelastungen
sind Gift für den Organismus der
vierjährigen
also wenn es wirklich so heiß ist ich
lasse die nachmittags nicht raus das
wäre aus dem Kindergarten kommen dann
gehen wir erstmal nach drinnen
ja und da liegt dann an mir weil sie
einfach noch zu klein ist dass ich
wirklich die ganze Zeit mit dem
Trinkbecher Flasche hinterherlaufe das
Kinderhilfswerk Unicef belegt in einer
neuen Studie die hitzebedingten
Erkrankungen von Kindern nehmen nicht
nur hierzulande sondern auch in anderen
Ländern zu wir sehen mit großer Sorge
dass bereits heute und jedes zweite Kind
in Europa von häufigen Hitzewellen
betroffen ist und uNICEF ruft deshalb
dazu auf Kinder dringend besser vor
Hitzewellen zu schützen die neue Studie
stellt fest weltweit sind derzeit 559
Millionen Kinder von Hitzewellen
betroffen bei einem Anstieg der
Erderwärmung um 1,7 Grad werden in den
nächsten Jahrzehnten noch mehr Kinder
darunter leiden über 2 Milliarden Kinder
auf der Welt werden bis 2050 Hitzewellen
ausgesetzt sein so Prognose die Familien
in den Entwicklungsländern leiden am
meisten unter den Klimawandel oder unter
den Folgen des Klimawandels obwohl sie
am wenigsten dazu beigetragen haben zum
Beispiel im südlichen Asien sind jetzt
schon drei Viertel aller Kinder von
extremer Hitze betroffen das sind häufig
Temperaturen die weit über 45 Grad
hinausreichen wie hier in Pakistan die
Kinder sie leiden unter Schwindel
Ohnmacht oder Organversagen und landen
immer häufiger in Notaufnahmen
weil die familienwirtschaftliche
notleiden müssen viele Kinder arbeiten
häufig unter freiem Himmel den
Straßenkindern fehlen trinkt
Möglichkeiten und kühle Räume um sich
darin aufzuhalten
Kinderschutzorganisationen und Ärzte
fordern dazu auf weltweit mehr in
hitzeschutzpläne zu investieren auch
hierzulande denn die Zeit drängt
Hitzewellen werden häufiger und
intensiver auftreten überall
und bei dir geht es jetzt mit den
Waldbränden in Griechenland weiter ja in
der waldbrandregion im Nordosten
Griechenlands sind in einer Hütte die
Leichen von 18 Menschen entdeckt worden
die Polizei geht derzeit davon aus dass
es sich bei den Opfern um Migranten
handelt die von der Türkei aus
illegal in die EU eingereist waren seit
vier Tagen lodert in der Nähe der
Hafenstadt alexandropolis die schwere
Waldbrand zahlreiche umliegende
Ortschaften sowie ein Krankenhaus
mussten evakuiert werden mindestens vier
weitere große Feuer auf den Inseln
aus sowie nahe Athen haben sich bei
starkem Wind in der Nacht weiter
ausgebreitet
nach den verheerenden brennten auf
Hawaii hat US-Präsident beiden das
Katastrophengebiet besucht auf der
schwer getroffenen Insel Maui sprach er
mit Einsatzkräften und Betroffenen und
kündigte langfristige Hilfe an bei dem
brennenden sind mindestens 114 Menschen
ums Leben gekommen und hunderte werden
noch vermisst
und einen Monat nach der vorgezogenen
Parlamentswahl in Spanien hat König
Philippe Oppositionsführer Alberto mit
der Bildung einer neuen Regierung
beauftragt die konservative Volkspartei
von fercho hatte die Wahl gewonnen war
aber hinter den Erwartungen geblieben ob
er im Parlament genug Unterstützung aus
anderen Parteien hat um zum
Regierungschef gewählt zu werden ist
unklar
in Nordrhein-Westfalen haben die
Behörden im vergangenen Jahr deutlich
mehr Fälle von klaren Kriminalität
registriert das Innenministerium
verzeichnet in seinem Lagebild
6.573 Straftaten mit klaren Bezug
20,3% mehr als im Vorjahr etwa ein
Drittel der Straftaten waren laut
Landeskriminalamt sogenannte
hoheitsdelikte wie
raubkörperverletzung oder
Freiheitsberaubung
japan will nun ab Donnerstag
aufbereitetes Kühlwasser aus der
Atomruine Fukushima ins Meer leiten
einen entsprechenden Beschluss gab die
Regierung in Tokio bekannt und erklärte
auf dem Gelände der Atomruine gehe der
Platz zur Lagerung des Kühlwassers aus
die Internationale Atomenergiebehörde
hatte grünes Licht für die Verklappung
in dem Pazifik gegeben
Fischereiverbände und Nachbarländer wie
China protestieren dagegen
dass der Bundeskanzler und diverse
seiner Minister bzw Ministerinnen seit
Amtsantritt gleich mehrfach nach Afrika
gereist sind zeigt dass die
Bundesregierung dem Kontinent eine
wachsende Bedeutung zu ist in einer Welt
in der China und die USA die beiden mit
Abstand stärksten Mächte zunehmend in
Konfrontation zueinander stehen stellt
sich die Frage wo stehen all jene die
nicht Zuge 7 oder NATO gehören die
Absichten China sind dort ziemlich
eindeutig alles einsammeln was man
früher als blockfrei bezeichnete und ein
Gegengewicht zum Westen bilden dafür
soll vor allem auch das brixformat den
bricks Abkürzung der Mitgliedsländer
Brasilien Russland Indien China
Südafrika
über das Gipfel Treffen der brix-staaten
und welche Interessen China in Afrika
hat berichten ihren Fritzsche und Verena
Gerald
27 km chinesische Investition der
Nairobi Express way viele hatten die
Autobahn sehen liest erwartet in der
Hoffnung dass sie den berüchtigten
Verkehrsstau in Kenias Hauptstadt
abmelden kann der 764 Millionen teure
Verkehrsweg hebt die Zusammenarbeit von
Kenia und China auf eine neue Stufe gut
vorbei geht Bahnhöfe helfen Züge china
investiert afrikaweit in große
Infrastrukturprojekte und plant für die
Zukunft noch mehr davon an Markt der
lange unterschätzt wurde heute ist
Afrika attraktiver denn je
wir haben mehr Menschen unter 50 und 60
Jahren als jede andere Region der Welt
wenn man sich also die Wirtschaft der
Zukunft mal anschaut jeder der plant
jeder der Produkte verkauft erkennt dass
diese einen größeren Markt in Afrika
haben werden als woanders
und das ist was China will den Markt
auch darum wird es gehen beim
brix-gipfel in Johannesburg da passte
das Bild heute Vormittag Südafrikas
erster Gast war Chinas Präsident hi
großer aufsteigende Volkswirtschaften
will er um sich scharen und sie scheinen
Schlange zu stehen allein aus Afrika
sollen 30 Staats- und Regierungschef vor
Ort sein
wir müssen unsere strategische
Zusammenarbeit stärken echten
Multilateralismus praktizieren und den
Ausbau unserer Stimme im globalen Süden
fördern
Südafrika rollt den roten Teppich aus
der Gipfel einstellig ein des globalen
südensstaatschefs eine multipolare Welt
die nicht vom Westen dominiert wird vor
allem seit Russlands Angriff auf die
Ukraine hat das Bündnis an Bedeutung
gewonnen
der russische Präsident erfielt in
Johannesburg ihm hätte in Südafrika die
Verhaftung gedroht per Video
zugeschaltet gibt er am frühen Abend ein
langes statement
unsere Zusammenarbeit basiert auf den
Grundsätzen der Gleichberechtigung der
partnerschaftlichen Unterstützung und
der Achtung der Interessen der anderen
dass er bei diesem für Russland so
wichtigen Gipfel nicht dabei sein kann
eine schwach
für Putin ist das eine echte Niederlage
man muss sich vorstellen das ist der
wichtigste Gipfel in der brix-geschichte
es könnte die erste Erweiterung des
Bündnisses in einer wirklich große
Allianz sein
die wirklich große Allianz viele neue
Mitglieder möglichst schnell das wollen
beide Russland und China ob es dazu
kommt ist ungewiss zu heterogenen die
Gruppe die Handelsinteressen
unterschiedlich beim vier augengespräch
zwischen China als Präsident Chi mit
Südafrikas Präsident Rama Posa zumindest
kam es heute schon zu einem Ergebnis
china hat den Gastgeber Gelder für
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit zugesagt
dass man ja vertiefen mit Professor
Guntram Wolf Direktor der Deutschen
Gesellschaft für auswärtige Politik von
Haus aus ist der Volkswirt Ökonomen mit
Schwerpunkt geoökonomie das große Bild
also und war vielfach als Politikberater
auf der internationalen Bühne tätig
guten Abend Herr Professor Wolf ja guten
Abend Frau wenn sie diesen Gipfel
beobachten welche Strategie verfolgt
China da und machen die anderen damit ja
china möchte eindeutig eine führende
Nation sein möchte den globalen Süden um
sich scharen und behauptet zwar dass es
um Multilateralismus geht aber
letztendlich geht es darum möglichst
viele Länder in den chinesischen Block
hineinzuziehen und damit tatsächlich
Einfluss zu üben und das Weltgeschehen
die Weltordnung neu zu prägen
aber da steht China dann mit weitem
Abstand eigentlich als Weltmacht alleine
da also wir haben ja auch eben im
Bericht noch mal das Wort multipolare
Welt gehört aber so richtig multipolar
ist die eigentlich nicht
es gibt eigentlich zwei große
Supermächte die USA und China und in im
bricks vereint sich natürlich sehr große
Länder 40 Prozent der Weltbevölkerung
ist dort
26% des der Wertschöpfung in der Welt
ist dort aber am Ende ist es China dass
diese brix-konstellation dominiert und
das natürlich möchte dass möglichst alle
sich eng an China richten gegen die G7
gegen die USA darum geht es den Chinesen
einen an einer Ambition war ja auch eine
Art eigenes Währungssystem zu schaffen
oder zumindest unabhängiger vom Dollar
zu werden aber kann das in absehbarer
Zeit gelingen
ja da sind sie noch weit von entfernt
die Chinesen versuchen das die
briggsstaaten versuchen das aber das
Finanzsystem bleibt weiterhin stark vom
Dollar dominiert an zweiter Stelle kommt
der Euro es ist sehr sehr schwer
wirklich dann eine Alternative
aufzubauen und das große Problem für die
Chinesen ist tatsächlich dass die
Chinesen im Prinzip ihre Währung
geschlossen halten eben Investitionen
nicht erleichtern in ihr Land sondern im
Gegenteil
Finanzströme eher kontrollieren und das
dann fällt es natürlich schwer die
chinesische oder eine gemeinsame Währung
sogar zu schaffen als Alternative zum
Dollar ich meine china hat ja im Moment
auch einige wirtschaftliche Probleme
ja China ist sicherlich nicht mehr in
dieser hochwachstumsphase in der es
früher einmal war es hätte demografische
Probleme die Bevölkerung altet altert
massiv auch
Innovationen schwächt sich eher ab die
produktivitätszahlen sind eher schlecht
also insofern braucht China wirklich
jetzt auch neue Märkte braucht neue
Partner neue Bündnispartner aber Länder
wie Indien oder Brasilien möchten eben
nicht nur nach China gucken sie möchten
auch in die USA gucken und sie möchten
mit uns Europäer natürlich auch im
Geschäft bleiben und deswegen sollten
wir unbedingt ein Handelsabkommen mit
Markus zur mit den Brasilianern und
Lateinamerika abschließen das hängt ja
noch quasi in der Luft nun geht's ja
nicht nur um ökonomische Faktoren auch
bei diesen brexit Treffen wenn man sich
jetzt die G7 ansieht die ja auch eine
Wertegemeinschaft sein wollen als
freiheitliche Demokratien auf der
anderen Seite die brix-staaten die
zumindestens die Gemeinsamkeit haben
dass sie sich ich sag mal etwas salopp
nicht fies Russland sind
ja in der Tat sind sie nicht klar gegen
Russland aber ich würde es auch nicht
überinterpretieren wollen ein Land wie
Brasilien möchte einfach nicht da
einfach das narrativ Westeuropas und der
USA übernehmen aber natürlich ist der
afrikanische Kontinent insbesondere
schaut schon auch kritisch auf diesen
Krieg denn ähm es fehlt an Lebensmitteln
und ich glaube es wird schon verstanden
dass Russlands Politik die weltweiten
nahrungsmittelmärkte tatsächlich ja in
Mitleidenschaft gezogen hat war ja auch
ganz interessant das Putin nicht
anreisen konnte also dass man ihm so
sehr deutlich zu verstehen gegeben hat
du das bitte nicht übrigens und sind die
blöde Lage dich verhaften zu müssen also
an dieser Art von internationalen Regeln
die ja nun auch Werte basiert westlich
orientiert sind hält man sich dann schon
ja ich denke schon dass Putin natürlich
als Gast erst eingeladen war aber dann
natürlich nicht physisch nicht in Person
kommt sondern nur online also man hat da
ein Kompromiss gewählt und ein Land wie
Südafrika auch das Land möchte natürlich
sowohl mit dem Westen gut können ist
auch westlich stark angebunden wie eben
auch mit China also insofern überlegt
man sich dann doch zweimal bevor man
tatsächlich dann den Westen und den
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof
ignoriert
Wolfgang für die Analyse danke schön
und mit Wirtschaft geht es jetzt bei dir
noch mal weiter eins ja das wechselhafte
Wetter trübt die vorläufige Ernte Bilanz
laut dem Deutschen Bauernverband sei der
vorjahresertrag beim Getreide in diesem
Jahr nicht mehr zu erreichen häufige
Niederschläge hätten die Ernte erschwert
steigende Preise erwartet man für das
Brotgetreide vorerst jedoch nicht andere
Pflanzen profitierten von den
Niederschlägen für Kartoffeln und Gemüse
etwa werden gute Erträge erwartet
und jetzt zur Börse und zu sina-meinitz
mit einem Blickrichtung US-Börse ja an
der New Yorker Technologiebörse Nasdaq
soll im September ein sehr interessanter
Börsengang stattfinden das britische
Unternehmen arm ist der Öffentlichkeit
vielleicht nicht so bekannt hält aber
eine Schlüsselrolle in der Chip
Industrie inne nach Firmenangaben steckt
in mehr als 90% aller Smartphones
weltweit eine Technik von ARM das
Unternehmen beschäftigt rund 6000
Mitarbeiter und kann Schwergewichte wie
Apple und Google zu seinen Kunden und
Partnern zählen auch wenn Arm im Moment
keine Wachstumsgeschichte vorweisen kann
und der Umsatz des Unternehmens zuletzt
gesunken ist wird hier auf die Zukunft
gesetzt und die heißt künstliche
Intelligenz die Verbindung von Chips und
KI gilt an der Börse als Erfolgsformel
erfolgreich war heute auch der DAX
erschließt den Handel im Plus bei einem
Stand von rund
15.706 Punkten investiert wird am
Aktienmarkt und auch zunehmend in den
Bau von chip-fabrik en die mit
Milliarden Hilfen subventioniert werden
auch in Deutschland erlangt die
Fertigung von Halbleitern eine immer
größere Bedeutung
unabhängiger werden von Asien ist
oberstes Ziel doch diese Chip Offensive
soll auch Arbeitsplätze schaffen und den
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland stärken
vielen Dank
Deutschlands hockeyfrauen ziehen bei der
Heim mit drei deutlichen Siegen in der
Vorrunde ins Halbfinale ein im
abschließenden Gruppenspiel gegen Irland
gewann die deutsche Mannschaft in
Mönchengladbacher Hockeypark 5:0 das
diabe-team ist damit Gruppenerster und
trifft in der Runde der letzten vier
Teams am Donnerstag auf Belgien
der italienische Sänger und
Songschreiber toto cutugno ist tot sein
wohl bekannteste Hit in Deutschland war
in italiano
[Musik]
feierte seine größten Erfolge in den
80er und 90ern er verstarb im Alter von
80 Jahren nach langjähriger Krankheit
[Musik]
es gibt ja wunderbare Geschichten von
Buchverlagen die einen Manuskript
ablehnten das später zu Weltliteratur
wurde
zum Beispiel reichte seinen Moby Dick
zunächst vergeblich ein ein Lektor
schrieb ihm zurück in die Geschichte ist
ja ganz nett aber muss der Wahl sein
oder
als er seinen Roman der große Gatsby
einem Verlag schickte
Charakter den sollten Sie besser
streichen
immerhin wurde ihnen wenigstens
geantwortet wenn unbekannte Autoren
einen Verlag für ihr Erstlingswerk
suchen bekommen sie meist nicht mal
Feedback auf und verlangt eingesandte
Manuskripte die Autorin die unserer
Kulturredakteur Claudio Armbruster
gleich vorstellt hat hingegen den
Autoren Traum erlebt sie schrieb einen
Roman las bei einem Literaturwettbewerb
daraus vor und zack erst rissen sich
Agenten und Verlage um sie und jetzt ist
sie auch noch für den Deutschen
Buchpreis nominiert
14 ist ein beschissenes Alter um seine
Mutter zu verlieren die Trauer kommt und
geht wie Ebbe und Flut aber da ist sie
immer meine Mutter wurde am heißesten
Tag des Jahres beerdigt die Vögel
strauchelten am weißen Himmel und die
Eidechsen zogen sich in die Schatten der
Grabsteine zurück die Hitze dehnte die
Zeit und verlangsamte alle Bewegungen
das klingt traurig ist es auch aber
nicht nur die Geschichte der 14-jährigen
billy ist nicht nur herzzerreißend
sondern auch herzerwärmend Lilly weiß
nicht wer ihr Vater ist sie verliert
ihre Mutter aber sie hat eine tausend
köpfige Ersatzfamilie die Bewohner der
Hochhaussiedlung in der sie wohnt
also die achten aufeinander die geben
sich halt die nehmen aufeinander
Rücksicht die helfen sich auch ganz
konkret aus auch mal mit Geld und ich
glaube man könnte fast sagen dass das
Hochhaus wie ein Protagonist ist in
diesem Roman also da wird ja auch eine
ganz bestimmte Atmosphäre erzeugt
man gewöhnt sich an die Höhe muss ich
feststellen geht so
sie hat sich diese Geschichte ausgedacht
Elena Fischer 36 seit in Mainz
Filmwissenschaft und Komparatistik
studiert und geschrieben Paradise Garden
ist ihr erster Roman und dieses
Interview ist ihr erstes überhaupt ich
wusste da ist was und das will raus und
ich habe es aber einfach nicht gemacht
vielleicht auch aus Angst und naja man
soll ja mutig sein so das ist ja auch
was was für das Buch ganz wichtig ist
und das habe ich mich dann auch gehalten
und wie kam es dann dazu dass ein
debüh-roman dein deboroman gleich mal so
einen renommierten Verlag landete
das ist wirklich ein verdammtes Wunder
ich habe eine gute Agentur gefunden
nachdem ich beim open mike gelesen habe
mike ist ein großer Literaturwettbewerb
und ja dann hat meine wunderbare Agentin
dass Manuskript an mehrere Verlage
geschickt letztlich haben sich Sex
Verlage für dieses Manuskript
interessiert und dann wurde es die Jonas
und jetzt erscheint
ich bin die ganze Zeit aufgeregt
[Musik]
ihre Romanfigur Billy fährt nach den Tod
der Mutter mit deren Auto los mit 14 der
Roman wird zum Road Trip zur magischen
Reise auf der Suche nach dem unbekannten
Vater natürlich ist es nicht realistisch
dass eine 14-Jährige nach dem Tod ihrer
Mutter ins Auto steigt und durch ganz
Deutschland fährt aber es ist ein Buch
und es ist Fiktion und ich wollte nicht
so triviale Dinge schildern die
Autobahnen und Verfolgungsjagden sondern
mir ging es darum eine innere
Entwicklung abzubilden und ja sie zu
zeigen wie sie sich zurechtfindet also
es ist eigentlich auch eine innere Reise
nicht nur äußereisen
und am Ende so viel da verraten werden
Geschehen kleine Wunder dieser Roman ist
ja auch ein kleines Wunder auf jeden
Fall aber eine große Überraschung
[Musik]
das war zum heute schon mal gleich
geht's mit der Reportage Reihe 37 Grad
weiter heute unter dem Titel wir retten
unser Dorf über Menschen die für ihr
Leben auf dem Land kämpfen und um 0 Uhr
gibt es dann unsere heute schon mal
Update mit Sandra Maria kronewald bis
morgen wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter auf dem Atlantik
ist einiges los und auf dieser Animation
sehen sie ganz im Norden Nordamerika und
nach Süden in Südamerika und dazwischen
sind sie ja einige Systeme das sind
tropenstürmer und Hurricane die jetzt
sehr viel Futter haben denn das Wasser
dort ist sehr warm teils rekordwarm
dementsprechend können die sich gut
entwickeln ja und bei uns ist es
ziemlich ruhig wir haben es mit hohen
Luftdruck zu tun europaweit und
entsprechend heiß ist es Richtung
Spanien Temperaturen hier über 40 Grad
aber auch das Wasser ist ebenfalls
Rekord warm das Mittelmeer wir schauen
in die Nacht da gibt's im Südosten Regen
ansonsten aber trocken hier und da Nebel
und auch einige Wolken insgesamt kommt
aber nichts runter und die Temperaturen
sinken auf 17 bis 19 Grad im Süden die
also deutlich milder als im Norden falls
nur 12 bis 16 Grad ja und hier könnt ihr
aber gut durchlüften denn es wird morgen
wieder warm
morgen dann im Tagesverlauf im Süden
Quellwolken und aus diesen Quellwolken
können sich dann Gewitter entwickeln
ganz im Norden gibt es auch Schauern
dazwischen harmlose Wolken und etwas
mehr Sonnenschein nach Südwesten hin
Temperaturen erreichen höchste Werte von
35 Grad hier eine extreme Wärmebelastung
21 bis 23 im Norden und teils 29 im
Osten ja und die nächsten Tage da tut
sich was Donnerstag kommt am Abend schon
Gewittertätigkeit auf im Westen und dann
am Freitag teils mit Unwettern
Starkregen Sturmböen und Hagel damit
müssen wir dann rechnen ein schöner
Abend